سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير سعود بن نايف
اصحاب المعالي الوزراء اصحاب السعاده
الحضور الكريم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته مره اخرى
نحتفل اليوم ببدء تنفيذ مشروع الربط
الكهربائي بين شبكه الربط الكهربائي لدول
المجلس التعاون الخليجي
وشبكه جنوب جمهوريه العراق حبيبه الذي تم
توقيع عقدهم تنفيذه بين الربط الكهربائي
وزاره الكهرباء في العراق
على هامش قمه جده للامن والتنميه في يوليو
الماضي
والذي يمثل
والذي يمثل احد المشروعات التي تهدف الى
تعزيز عواصر التعاون بين دول المجلس
والعراق الشقيق
في المجالات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه بشكل
عام واشمل
وبمناسبه الخطوه المباركه
مددت ان ارفع اسم ايات
الشكر والعرفان الى مولاي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز والى
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ولي العهد رئيس مجلس
الوزراء
ولا والى طبعا اصحاب الجلاله والسمو قادت
دول مجلس التعاون
والى القياده العراقيه الشقيقه لمساندتهم
المستمره ودعمهم متواصل لمشروع الربط
الكهربائي الخليجي الذي ياتي
كجزء من كل
وان كنت اعتقد
وهو خروج على ما كتب لي ان ما يربطنا ليست
انابيب ولا خطوط كهرباء بل هي اورده وعروق
بيننا جميعا انساب واحبه وبين لنا قبائل
وما يجمعنا هو اكبر واشمل من كما ذكرت
انابيب بخطوط كهرباء
[تصفيق]
صاحب السمو لحضور الكريم
الربط الكهربائي هو توجه يتبناه كثير من
الدول رايناه في اوروبا وراينا في اماكن
اخرى
هذا الاهتمام هو محقق
لتعزيز امن الشبكات المرتبطه
باستقرارها وتعظيم الفوائد الاقتصاديه
منها وزياده قدراتها على
ادماج مصادر الطاقه المتجدده فيها
ولما يسم به من ايجاد سوق اقليميه
ونطمح ان تكون يومه سوق دوليه لتبادل
الطاقه الكهربائيه وتصديرها
وفي هذه السياق انشات
انشات شبكه الربط الكهربائي لدول المجلس
التعاون وكان حلما
كان يعتقد الجميع انه كان حلما لكنه الان
اصبح واقعا
وكان حلم الربط مع العراق كان حلما فاصبح
واقعا وانا يعني ولدت ان اشكر اصحاب
المعالي
لتعاونهم معي في هذا الخصوص
لانه كان الموضوع معطل بفتره طويله ومتاخر
لفتره طويله
فما كان ينظر له على انه حقيقه ستاتي
بقي حلما
يودي الجميع تحقيقه الا انه الان الحمد
لله تحقق بتعاون الاخوان في الجانب
العراقي
ايضا
هناك حقيقه ايضا انه كانت مبادره في
الاساس من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
للربط الخليجي ولذلك كان بدايه تمويل
الربط الخليجي او تمويل من الصندوق
السعودي للتنميه الصناعيه
والتي قام بتنفيذها كل من معهد البحوث في
جامعه الملك فهد للبترول والمعادن
معهد الابحاث الكويتيه مقلب معهد الابعاد
العلميه الكويتيه مع بعض الاستشاريين
العالميين
وباشراف فريق عمل فني من الدول الاعضاء
وما اتبعها من دراسات تفصيليه
اكدت المنافع التي يمكن ان تجنيها الدول
من الربط الكهربائي وهي الان الحمد لله
صارت حقيقه ملموسه
في الصيف وفي كل صيف يرى جميع المعنيين في
هذه القطاع حجم الفائده المتحققه من الربط
ومن توفير امكانيه
زياده في الطاقه الغير منتجه الغير مستغله
لدى بعض الدول في توفير احتياجات قد تكون
مؤقته وقد تكون مستدامه نظرا لظروف الصيف
التي كلنا نعرفها
انما نتيجه لهذه الدراسات تم اعداد تنفيذ
المرحله الاولى من مشروع في قمه مسقط عام
1997 ميلادي
واليوم ترى دوله دول مجلس جميعها الفوائد
المتحققه كما اسلفت من هذا المشروع منذ ان
بدا تشغيله في عام
2009 ميلادي
اما فيما يتعلق بمشروع الربط الكهربائي
السعودي العراقي المباشر فما كما اسلف
فانه يجري تنفيذ مبادئ اتفاق الربط
الموقعه بين الجانبين الشقيقين وكان في
شهر رمضان
لقاء طويل مع صحف عالي وزير العراقي وشركه
اكوا وما زلنا نتابع هذا الموضوع اخر من
حوالي اسبوعين
في اجتماع اللجنه السعوديه العراقيه
المشتركه
حيث يمتد هذه المشروع من مدينه عرعر شمال
المملكه الى اليوسفيه ورب بغداد
وتبلغ سعه الاوليه
الف ميجا وات
وسيدعم المشروع بالاضافه الى مشروع ربط
الكهربائي الخليجي العراقي عند اكتمالهما
وتشغيلهما
الشبكه الكهربائيه العراقيه
يجب ان اذكر هذا الجزء من كل متابع كلمه
للامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان في مناسبه بدء
تنفيذ مشروع الربط الكهربائي الخليجي ما
بين دول مجلس الخليجي
ودوله العراق
الاخبار
هناك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات